♪♪
-We're going to get to the news.
Former President Trump defended
his children over the weekend
against the New York State
Attorney General Letitia James'
lawsuit, and said, quote,
"Ivanka --
Ivanka is a very good person.
Don Jr., he's a good person.
Eric -- Eric --
these are good people."
So, if there's one thing --
one thing he's learned
from this lawsuit,
it's all of their names.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
President Biden initially
worried his student debt
forgiveness plan wouldn't
go over well
with working-class people,
and told his advisers, quote,
"The federal government
shouldn't be bailing out
Ivy League graduates."
I mean, at least not until
they become bank presidents.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, I got Bernie Sanders
backstage.
I'm going to play to him
a little bit, all right?
[ Laughter ]
At the Global Citizen music
festival in New York
over the weekend
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
appeared to be booed
by the crowd.
To be fair, she completely
flubbed her solo.
[ Laughter ]
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
has warned of potential
evacuation orders
this week in advance of
Hurricane Ian.
The two aren't related, he just
loves kicking people out.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book
about his business dealings,
former president Trump once
received a lease payment
in boxes of gold bricks
and asked his security guard,
Matthew Calamari,
to bring them to his Trump Tower
apartment.
Is it just me or does every
new Trump story sound
like a 9-year-old wrote
a mafia movie?
[ Laughter ]
[Mobster accent]
"Forget about it, Calamari.
This town belongs
to Johnny Pizza."
[ Laughter ]
[Normally]
House Republicans on Friday
announced their new
Congressional platform,
which featured a quote
misattributed
to Abraham Lincoln.
Apparently,
he never actually said
"Disney+ is grooming
our children."
[ Laughter ]
Kanye West appeared to comment
on his divorce
with Kim Kardashian in
an Instagram story yesterday
and said, quote, "London,
I know how you feel.
I lost my Queen too."
It's sweet that he thinks Kim
is a queen,
but weird that he thinks London
is a country.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, oh, well aren't you
the Queen of London?"
[ Light laughter ]
In an upcoming book, former
President Trump describes
"New York Times" reporter
Maggie Haberman
as his psychiatrist,
or that's just what he calls
any lady with glasses.
[ Light laughter ]
Former FBI director James Comey,
announced recently
that he will release
a mystery novel series.
Let me guess, Hillary did it?
[ Laughter ]
Or she didn't, or she maybe did,
but you're unclear about it?
A teen in Canada recently set
a Guinness world record
after putting 22 socks
on one foot in 30 seconds,
all because her father refuses
to let anyone
touch the thermostat.
[ Laughter ]
NYU will offer a new course
this fall
focused on singer Lana Del Rey's
music.
To qualify, you must have
completed at least two semesters
of Lexapro.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
more than half of Americans said
that they have muted themselves
during a virtual meeting
to pass gas.
Even worse,
the other half just didn't.
[ Laughter ]
According to estimates from
the Congressional Budget Office,
President Biden's plan to
forgive $10,000 per borrower
in Federal Student loan debt
will cost nearly $400 billion.
Or, in student loan terms,
$27 a month
for 30 billion years.
[ Laughter ]
According to new data,
coronavirus cases
are rising in the U.K.,
maybe because last week,
the entire country
attended the same event.
[ Laughter ]
The White House announced
yesterday that President Biden
will host French President
Emmanuel Macron
later this year.
Which is great, but can we say
no gifts this time?
[ Laughter ]
[ French accent ] "We noticed
you did not have
a 305-foot woman, and..."
[ Laughter ]
"New York famously
has much space, oui?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] That's -- so,
in 2022,
one of our monologue writers
were like, "Enough.
I'm going after
the Statue of Liberty."
[ Laughter ]
Republican Congressman
Matt Gaetz announced last week
that he is starting
his own Twitch
streaming channel, and tweeted,
"I'm joining Twitch to bring
my America-first message to a
new generation of voters."
Previously, the only way
he reached a new generation
of voters was on Venmo.
[ Laughter ]
Scientists recently discovered
vaccine-resistant coronavirus
in Russian bats.
It's what Putin's calling
Plan B.
[ Laughter ]
"Release the bats."
A panel of doctors recommended
last week that all adults
under 65-years-old
should be regularly screened
for anxiety.
Said adults, "How regularly?
Like, once a year?
Once a month?
Every day?
Should we screen every day?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Rolling Stone" yesterday
published an updated
list of the 100 greatest
TV shows of all-time.
And I don't want to brag,
but I read the whole list.
[ Laughter ]
Not bad, not bad.
100, read 'em all.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
24% of Americans said
that they found it very easy
to make friends as a teenager,
and the other 76%
are the people they bullied.
[ Laughter ]
A woman in North Dakota
was arrested recently
after she allegedly brought
a wild raccoon into a bar.
Said the woman, "Oh, I thought
you said it was rabies night."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
So, the premise of Brian --
I'll say his name --
the premise of Brian's joke...
[ Laughter ]
...is that you would hear a bar
was having "ladies night"
and you would hear it
as "rabies night."
[ Laughter ]
Maybe that's a symptom
that you have rabies.
[ Laughter ]
You're home
with your pet raccoon,
and it bites you, and then,
like, an hour later,
you're like,
"Did I hear rabies night?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally --
we just let 'em all in, guys.
We're just finding out with you
if they're good or not,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according
to a new survey,
78% of animal owners said
that seeing their pet
when they come home is the best
part of their day.
Worst part of their day,
when their spouse
heard them say that.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
announced yesterday
that his administration
will lower the cost of insulin
for everyone, regardless
of their Medicare status.
And not a moment too soon.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't make that.
That's an actual product.
During the same event
at the White House yesterday,
President Biden
pulled out a copy
of Florida senator Rick Scott's
12-point plan to rescue America
and said that it could end
Social Security and Medicare.
Oh, that'll be popular
in Florida.
[ Laughter ]
What's his next idea?
Abolishing visits
from grandkids?
According to a new book,
former president Trump
would tell White House visitors
that he had a secret bathroom.
And visitors would tell him,
"Sir, that's just a closet."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
That's part of the secret.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] The book
also claims that while meeting
then-president Barack Obama
in 2016 after being elected,
former president Trump
asked Obama
how he kept his approval ratings
so high.
"What'd he say," asked Biden.
[ Laughter ]
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell said yesterday
that he will support
the bipartisan bill
to reform the
Electoral Count Act of 1887.
I guess he still feels bad
after voting no the first time.
[ Laughter ]
Britain's Prince George
reportedly told his classmates,
"My dad will be king,
so you better watch out."
[ Laughter ]
Which, you have to admit,
is a crushing comeback
for a 9-year-old.
"Tag, you're it."
"If by it you mean
the once and future king!"
New York mayor Eric Adams
announced yesterday
that he will launch
a chess council
to develop more
plant-based recipes
for public school lunches.
Meanwhile, most of
the high school students
will continue to enjoy
plant-based recess.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, after receiving
criticism from viewers,
Netflix removed the LGBTQ tag
from its new series
about serial killer
Jeffrey Dahmer.
On the downside, they left
the food and travel tag.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today declared
a major disaster in Florida,
and then Florida in turn
declared Biden a major disaster.
[ Laughter ]
The White House released
a 44-page plan yesterday
to fight hunger.
It's just
the Cheesecake Factory menu.
[ Laughter ]
Before the government runs out
of money tomorrow,
Congress is reportedly
set to pass stopgap legislation
to keep the government funded
through 2 1/2 more months.
Is it just me,
or is the government always
waiting until the last minute
to fund itself?
The federal government is like
a kid running for the school bus
with one pant leg on
holding a waffle.
[ Laughter ]
Queen Elizabeth's death
certificate was released today
and said that
she died of old age,
a condition she battled
for nearly 30 years.
[ Laughter ]
At a recent panel,
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
was booed by the crowd
after he said that
the best way
to stop school shootings
was to increase police presence
on campuses.
Cruz hadn't been booed that bad
since the last time
he walked into his house.
"Hey, family."
"Boo!"
Republican operatives
in Pennsylvania
are reportedly trying to push
the unfounded theory
that Democratic Senate candidate
and lieutenant governor
John Fetterman
is affiliated with a gang.
Even worse, they're trying to
push the unfounded theory
that Dr. Oz is affiliated
with Pennsylvania.
[ Laughter ]
The Netflix reality dating show
"Love Is Blind"
is reportedly casting
for a new season
to be set in Washington, D.C.
Said one contestant,
"Okay, so he's really quiet,
but an amazing listener."
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Tom Hanks said that
he made a ton of movies,
but added that he thinks
"four of them are pretty good,"
and then Vin Diesel said, "I've
also made a ton of movies."
[ Laughter ]
Tom Hanks announced
in the same interview
that next year he will release
his debut novel,
and no surprise here --
it's called
"World War II in Space."
[ Light laughter ]
Maybe a little surprise here.
And finally the airline
Virgin Atlantic yesterday
unveiled its new
gender-neutral uniform policy.
Flight attendants
can choose to wear
either pants, a skirt,
or the Chalamet.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪